So I'm here today with author Greg.
Greg is president of fire foundation for
individual rights in education and
Jonathan Heit is an eminent social
psychologist and professor of ethical
leadership at New York University's
Stern School of business.
They have coauthored a new book called
the coddling of the American mind,
which is an elaborated version of a
famous Atlantic monthly SSA.
They published a while back and so today
we're here to talk about their new book
and about the state of the universities
and I suppose society at large.
So thanks guys very much for joining me
today.
So I thought maybe we'd start talking
about the book.
So do you guys want to provide some
background?
Maybe you could talk about the Atlantic
monthly essay and what led up to the
book and then we'll get into the
details.
Sure.
It all started in 2007 when I was lucky
enough to have a full on medical level
of depression.
Really,
really bad.
I talk about it in some sort of detail
in the,
uh,
in the book I realized it's actually a
level at which I realized I wrote about
it with details that my wife doesn't
know.
There's a weird privacy thing that
sometimes happens when you're dictating
into a computer.
This is just between me and the computer
and now I realize it's probably the most
public thing,
but the thing that saved me,
the thing that ultimately helped me deal
with my depression general,
well as cognitive behavioral therapy,
um,
in a sense it's sort of like applied
stoicism.
You just look at your own thoughts.
You talked back to the really
exaggerated ones.
You've labeled them as cognitive
distortions that these include things
like generalization,
catastrophizing,
binary thinking,
thinking,
everything has to be there,
all good or bad.
I'm actually particularly guilty of
these.
And Amazingly,
if you just actually learned what these
distortions are and practice everyday to
sort of talk back to sort of the more
anxious or depressed voices in your own
head.
It's an incredibly effective treatment
for depression and anxiety.
And it changed,
absolutely changed my life.
Meanwhile,
as this is changing my life,
I'm still working,
I'm still the president of fire,
which means I defend free speech and due
process and academic freedom on campus.
And um,
while I was learning all of these
intellectual habits,
all of these ways to sort of talk
yourself down,
I was looking around at what
administrators we're doing and an ask
and saying to myself,
wow,
it's actually kind of like the
administrators are saying,
oh,
by the way,
you do engage in cognitive distortions,
do engage in binary thinking,
do overgeneralize and most of all
catastrophize all the time.
And I remember thinking something to the
effect of,
well thank goodness the students don't
seem to really be buying it.
And that's what changed in 2013,
2014 prior to 2013,
2014 since I started in 2001,
the worst constituency for free speech
on campus was actually administrators.
The best,
most reliable fans of free speech you
could run into on campus were generally
the students themselves.
And then sometime around 2013,
2014,
we saw a.
suddenly they were demanding everything
from trigger warnings to microaggression
policies to December stations for even
people,
but,
but both on the left and the right on
the spectrum and it seemed like we said
it seemed to happen almost overnight and
this,
uh,
and when I went to talk to John about
it,
we'd become friends through a mutual
friend and I said,
it's almost that I talked about my whole
theory that we're teaching a generation
the habits of anxious and depressed
people from cognitive behavioral
therapy.
John got really excited about the idea,
um,
and asked if I wanted to write about it.
And I was already a fan of John's work.
So I was like,
absolutely.
Yeah.
So I thought that his insight into what
had changed was absolutely brilliant.
Uh,
I had just begun to notice this in my
own teaching.
I've been teaching since 1995 at the
University of Virginia originally and it
was seemingly overnight,
right around 2014.
These new ideas,
you know,
students of course are political.
They protest,
they object to things,
but what was new Grad?
Put his finger on it.
What was new was the idea that these
words are going to harm me,
not just defend me,
not just be unjust,
harm me.
We have to protect.
It was this idea that students are
fragile and need protection and the
protection should come from
administrators,
from adults.
That's what was new and disturbing.
Yeah.
Will you guys talk in the book about
concept creep and the overgeneralization
of the idea of trauma and you know,
one of the things that's really struck
me as interesting about the safe space
movement and the microaggression
policies and all of that is that it does
run so contrary to what every clinician
worth his or her salt knows about
treating anxiety or depression and it
one so.
So that's kind of a remarkable.
A phenomenon in itself is that what we
know clinically has been absolutely
inverted by people who are
hypothetically agitating on the part of
students' mental health.
And it's not as if the mental health
community has stood up on moss and
denounced this.
So.
And I also don't.
I don't understand that.
I also don't understand how we got here.
You guys talk in the book a little bit
about your little bit of,
you hypothesize a little bit about the
internet generation.
Right?
And those are the kids born after 1995.
You don't put the finger on the
millennials but.
But let's talk a little bit about why
you think things changed in 2013 and
2014.
Let me just first say your point about
this whole,
these whole,
these new ideas are not clinically
supported.
Something that we suggest in the book.
We know,
we don't know if this is going on.
To what extent is this a sincere desire
for protection and a sincere belief that
students are fragile and to what extent
is it the pursuing of a political agenda
and,
and making political points and using
mental health as a cover.
I think both are operative and and so,
and it may depend on the context.
Why do you think the first one is
operative?
Because this runs so contrary to
everything that's known about the actual
protection of mental health.
I'm very skeptical about attributing a
positive motivation to it.
Like,
it seems to me that it's fundamentally
driven by resentment.
Well,
it's
so,
uh,
so you're absolutely right that the
psychological community does not support
this,
but yet has not stood up very vocally to
condemn it.
So we are hopeful that psychologists and
psychiatrists,
everyone we spoke to,
agreed that ends over only exactly the
worst thing to do for someone who
suffers from ptsd is to sweep clean
their daily life of reminders,
thereby denying them the chance to
situate,
to decondition the,
uh,
the power of these quotes triggers in
the real world.
It's worse in some sense too because one
of the things you do when you expose
people who have anxiety disorders to the
things that are anxious about is not
make them less anxious,
but make them more courageous.
Right?
And that's why it generalizes because
the psychoanalysts thought that exposure
would just mean the fears would pop up
somewhere else,
but they don't.
And it's because people learn that
there's more to them than they thought.
And then when you protect them,
not only do not expose them,
which is a big problem,
but you also teach them to generalize.
The idea of their weakness,
which is a really terrible thing to do
to people so you couldn't invent more
counterproductive mental health movement
and instituted on campus is if you set
out to design it.
That's something that we always try to
emphasize.
So interesting for us to look at was the
one thing,
because,
you know,
the third anti free speech movement is
coming from students,
uh,
in the relatively recent past,
so late eighties and early nineties for
example.
But the thing that was so striking was
that they were medicalizing all,
all of these claims,
you know,
of course I'm sitting there going like,
that doesn't sound right.
And I talked to John and he was like,
I haven't sound right.
And we interviewed for the original
article,
maybe seven different clinical
psychologists,
cbt experts,
uh,
you know,
for example.
And the thing I keep on trying keep on
explaining it as it's,
as a fraternity up what could be a minor
version into something more like a
phobia because we're giving it so much
more power.
And the worst thing of all that we're
doing,
so much of our campuses,
we're turning it into a Schema.
We're turning the idea that I've,
that I'm broken into,
um,
into,
uh,
a permanent sort of self definition.
So that's why I do think that there's
sort of a mixed motive thing going
on here.
I think that we have a self fulfilling
prophecy going on to some degree because
I do think that some of this kind of
hopeless ideology is actually genuinely
Harvard students actually making them
more anxious and depressed.
And of course it's really incompatible
with
statistics to that end.
So one of the things you guys
concentrate on the book is,
is statistics indicating that there has
in fact been there is evidence of a
decline in mental health over the last.
What is it about the last decade
since around 22,000?
Nine to 2012 is when the elbow,
that's where things begin to,
to arch up.
And then they go steadily up to about
2015,
2016.
We don't know if they're still going up
or if they're plateauing,
but this is what's going into a little
bit of detail because it was just an
article in the New York Times.
Richard Friedman psychiatrist wrote an
article,
something about how the idea of a wave
of increased anxiety is a myth.
He said,
he said it's just based on one or two,
you know,
there've been some,
a couple of self report studies in which
students say that they're more anxious.
And he dismissed that and said,
don't worry America,
you kids aren't becoming more anxious.
So we thought we dug into this in
detail.
We did not want to catastrophize.
We did not want to foment a moral panic.
So we didn't want to say,
you know,
oh my God,
the sky is falling.
Kids are,
are,
are depressed and anxious.
So we looked into this in great detail.
Uh,
and we were.
So we were looking for this data in our
art Atlantic article and it wasn't
there.
Uh,
that is the anecdotes everywhere.
People were saying the mental health
centers are swamped.
So there were plenty of reports from
mental health centers,
but isn't this just because kids these
days are more comfortable seeking
treatment.
That's why the mental health centers is
swap.
Maybe there's no real increase.
So in Atlantic article we could not make
a strong case and we left it very
speculative,
but just two years later,
uh,
when Jean [inaudible] book came out,
I aged and she brought in data from,
for national nationally representative
surveys showing that it really is an
increased out.
Again,
those were almost all self report.
What convinced us,
but convince us that it's real is that
there was a,
there was a major study done published
in Jama,
Journal of American Medical Association
looking at hospital admission data.
So they broke it down by gender and you
always have to look male,
female,
separate.
They broke it down by sex and by age
group within teenagers and for all of
the age groups,
for four of the girls,
teenage girls hospital admissions for
cell part from cutting yourself,
taking voice.
This is nonfatal.
Um,
it's flat,
flat,
flat.
And then right around 2011,
2012,
2013,
he starts going up and up and up,
and of course the rate is lowest for 11
to 13 year old girl.
So let's let the do this.
But the increase was the largest and 20
says that social media is social
comparison seems to be hardest on the
youngest girls.
So the self harm data confirms this is
behavioral data.
This is not self report.
Uh,
and then the real kicker,
it's suicide.
If you look at the suicide statistics,
they showed the same pattern as the self
report of depression data,
which is,
um,
if you look at the first decade of the
century,
so 2000,
one to two to 2010,
the average,
a number of kids who killed themselves
successfully commits suicide.
The rate for boys from that decade,
uh,
through Twenty 15,
2016,
those two years of data,
it goes up and up and up up 25 percent,
which is gigantic.
There's been an enormous increase in
voice suicide.
The increase for girls is 70 percent,
seven zero.
So boys,
the rate is higher for boys because
girls make many more attempts,
but boys methods,
so the.
So the increase is actually fairly
parallel,
but as a percentage is much higher for
girls.
Social Media,
at least this is his argument and we
think there's some validity to it.
Twenties argument is that the spread of
of iphones and social media has brought
boys into play video games.
They play a lot of video games,
but those aren't actually that harmful.
It's the social comparison sites.
It's a instagram and and other things
where girls are comparing their lives to
other girls and feeling left out that we
think we don't know for sure,
but that we think is the most powerful
reason why the girls rates have
increased so much.
Oh sorry.
John Greenberg.
That data too,
because even since 2007,
if you just pick 2007,
we're talking about a doubling in terms
of suicide in 2007.
That was the.
That was the lowest year.
So if you just.
So it's,
that's why it's best to not take 2007.
It's best to just take the average
bounces around.
No trend in the first decade.
Okay.
So we could hypothesize perhaps that
there's something approximating a
positive feedback loop going on here.
So imagine because I'm trying to figure
out why things have gone out of control,
say since 2013,
it's like there's been a tipping point.
And so I'm going to offer a few ideas
and you guys can tell me what you think.
Okay.
So let's,
let's think of four or five reasons.
So I think there's an increase in
political perceived political
polarization and maybe real political
polarization because the mainstream
media,
mainstream media is dying and as it dies
it gets,
it gets more attracted to quick bait
journalism and exaggerates the degree of
extremism on both sides.
And that's a consequence of a
technological revolution that the threat
that they're under from probably from
Internet media sources.
So that's one.
The next one would be the UN.
I'm opposed,
rise of the postmodern Marxist doctrines
that characterize disciplines,
particularly like women's studies.
Now you guys talked about a woman who
generated,
um,
intersectionality theory,
Kimberle crenshaw,
and I'd been looking into Kate Millett
who established patriarchy theory or one
of the people who established it and she
was a radical lesbian for political
reasons and had an alcoholic and abusive
father.
So I think that's quite interesting and
I think that these theories,
crenshaw and,
and millets theories were basically
ignored by serious scholars in the,
in the academic world,
but they've spread and have had a
disproportionate effect on the
universities and their combined with a
kind of Marxist viewpoints that divides
the world into victimizer and victim.
And then maybe we have the,
what you just said.
Yep.
You Bet.
On the political polarization.
Absolutely.
We have a whole chapter on that.
The way to think about this as
universities are complicated
institutions nested within a broader
society and they're changing and the
broader society has changed.
And so we document how the rise in
political polarization and here the
thing to focus on is not polarization of
attitudes about abortion or things like
that is how much do you hate the other
side that has been going up steadily
since the 19 nineties.
And so if you have a left right battle,
it's getting more and more intense at
the same time as the professoriate is
going from leaning left to being much
further on the left.
So we document this in the book,
um,
that the,
the overall left right ratio for a
variety of reasons went from a two to
two,
one overall putting everybody to,
to one of the early nineties,
two,
five to one left,
right ratio by 2010.
So if you have a more politically
purified institution at a time when the
electromagnetic forces of crossbars and
hatred are ginning up,
then yes,
you have a more politicized institution.
So there's a lot going on there.
It's not unique to the left.
It just so happens that universities
have been polarizing,
left other institutions,
polarized,
right?
If you believe in diversity,
if you believe that diversity makes
people think better because it
challenges thoughts in a loss of
political diversity is harmful and it's
a contributor,
echo chambers that we agreed on the
Internet.
Social media does go to pat you on the
back for having those thick of an echo
chamber as possible.
Um,
I'm definitely a big proponent of sort
of the big sort of hypothesis certainly
lived this experience that we
increasingly live in a politically
homogeneous communities now.
Big Sort of course talks about us living
in more politically homogeneous
counties,
but Charles Murray and others have done
research about how we actually live even
more politically homogeneous city blocks
that actually we are sort of self
sorting.
Tyler Cowen talks about this too,
and of course if you have sort of a
social circle where you practically
never run into anybody who disagrees
with you.
The,
all the different sort of tribalism
experiments that they've done,
polarization experiments they've done
over the years shows that you attend to
sort of spiral off into the distance.
So that's one of the reasons why I think
of,
this is what we call him the book of
problem with progress,
but if you think about the idea that we
can live in communities that reflect our
values going back around late 19
seventies,
that sounds lovely.
That sounds great,
Ray,
to live in communities for my values,
but if you've ever lived in a,
that reflects just one political point
of view and virtually none of the other.
It does have a tendency to become a
virtue signal,
a contest more than an actual place
where you discuss ideas.
Okay.
So now let's move on to the services of
Marxism.
Um,
so I think you and I both agree that
that postmodernism Marxism,
uh,
that these are lenses that tend to
amplify conflict.
These are somehow involved.
Uh,
I think you and I may disagree a bit on
the dynamics here and the extent of it.
So I'll just leave it.
The way that I think about it,
these ideas,
this way of looking at things,
even these ideas of of trigger warnings,
matrices of oppression,
those ideas existed in feminist circles
going all the way back to the nineties
as a professor at Nyu and previous that
Uva,
I have not seen that postmodernism or
Marxism or in any way spreading across
the disciplines.
They've always been there in a few
disciplines.
There's a lot of of Marxist analysis and
sociology.
I have not noticed that spreading at all
among the professoriate or across
disciplines.
I think what has happened is that social
media and the Internet,
especially social media has knocked down
the compartments a good society needs a
lot of compartments,
needs a lot of walls,
were different norms and different
practices flourish that you can do
different jobs.
I think social media is knocked down the
walls so that certain ideas that maybe
some students get from their gender
studies or anthropology or sociology
classes,
those ideas can spread among the
students and they're often not even
really the accurate ideas.
That's a sort of a bastardized version,
a modified in ways that I don't really
even understand that can spread around.
This is how you can get bad
psychological ideas that political ideas
spreading around among the students.
That's what's been most striking to us
is that this is really the change is
really student led.
It's a generational thing.
You can blame faculty and in certain
departments for.
You can certainly disagree with their
ideas,
but it's not that there's this
conspiracy as far as we can tell a
conspiracy,
one of the professors to take over.
Maybe you'll disagree with that.
We see it.
I see it as more student led.
I didn't want to talk a lot about John
and I talk a lot about,
but it didn't quite make it into the
book.
What we've dubbed it is the fortress.
And what we mean by that is if you look
at the way,
like I,
I went to Stanford for law school,
I worked for the Eclu of Northern
California.
Um,
and I saw this sort of happening even in
the early nineties that one of the
things that some of these postmodern
theories,
particularly privileged theory allow is
a matter of arguing in which you never
ever have to get to the substance of the
argument.
So even in the late nineties,
reformable borders had a lot of levels
of protection.
You didn't have to listen to anybody if
they're conservative was almost taken
for granted,
which I deeply ashamed of.
Um,
you didn't have to,
uh,
and now if you add to it,
you don't have to listen to anybody.
If they have privilege.
And by the way 100 percent of people
actually do,
that means you can choose to listen to
whomever the hell you want because it's
only optional.
You have an option to either dismiss
marks a as being a white privileged male
or you can listen to them.
But anytime you run into someone who
disagrees with you,
you have several sort of tools at your
disposal.
The was that were white males defending
our privileged.
Almost nobody engaged with the substance
of the argument.
Yeah,
boiled down to the power claims of
competing identity groups.
Then there is no such thing as substance
and I think that actually fits quite
nicely with certain strains of
postmodern thinking that have a tendency
to deny any knowledge of any real world
and to presume that everything is not
only interpretation interpretation based
on a power claims for competing groups
and the intersectionality theory.
You know,
I just finished writing the preface to
that new version of the Fiftieth
Anniversary version of the Gulag.
Archipelago was quite something and I
was trying to synthesize Solzhenitsyn's
arguments about why the Russian
revolution went so badly south
immediately after it began.
And it's very interesting to think about
it from this intersectionality
perspective because as you guys just
pointed out,
it's not an unreasonable proposition
that people have multiple,
multiple group identities.
Now.
Perhaps there's some use in considering
that because you can think of the ways
that people have different advantages
and disadvantages,
but one of the real pernicious side
effects of that kind of thinking,
especially when it's conjoined with a
viewpoint that divides the world into
victim and victimizer,
is that you can take any one person and
maybe generate 20 group identities for
them and you can find at least one
identity along which they're privileged
and that means that not only can you
ignore them as a consequence of them
speaking only on behalf of their power,
but you have a valid reason for
persecuting them,
and that's exactly what happened in the
Soviet Union.
As long as I could find one dimension
along which you were an oppressor,
then you were done.
Yeah,
right.
Right.
Well,
they were the best example of that.
Any other countries where search.
That's where my family comes from and in
any other country,
you know,
my family's story would have been
because we went from being to being
lawyers and judges within a single
generation.
My grandfather was in Kiev,
polytechnic studying to be a professor
when World War One broke out and of
course people like me,
success stories and any other country we
were shot in the back of the head by the
millions.
Right,
right.
Well,
and you were actually the working class
success stories because when,
when was,
when was eradicated in,
in,
in Russia.
Right,
right.
So people
were basically slaves up to that point
and some people made very rapid,
uh,
leaps in status within a single
generation or two.
And those were the Kulaks that were
medicated by the,
by the Soviets after World War One.
Then that,
of course,
that's what led to the huge starvation
and massive starvation of the 19,
late 1920 [inaudible] and 1930
[inaudible] and early 19 thirties.
So it was a complete catastrophe.
So.
Alright.
So we,
you put together a bunch of symptoms,
you know,
you said well,
microaggression theory,
I'm no admirer of Daryl is derald wing
sue?
Yes.
I think that,
that.
I read his book,
I thought it was absolutely appalling.
And in all in all possible manners.
There's the,
the kind of oppression theory and
intersectionality,
the idea that we're in a patriarchal
tyranny,
and then one of the things that you've
pointed out at the beginning of this
interview was the unknown effect of
social comparison with these new social
technologies,
social media technologies,
right?
Because we're really at a really laid
vulnerable to these new technologies
because we have no idea what the effect
they have on adults,
let alone young people.
And so do you think that is actually
making young people feel that the world
is a more dangerous place and requiring
them to seek protection?
Oh yes.
We think that's a big part of it.
Physical Safety,
safe or unsafe for death rates go down
so you know Steve Pinker and many
others,
a chronicle of the decline of violence,
but we react to the world not as it is.
We react to the world as we perceive it
through the filters that were given.
And if,
if you remember the old movie from the
19 eighties or nineties,
it was the bowling for columbine boy,
Michael Moore's movie,
bowling for Columbine,
where he traces out why Americans are so
paranoid compared to Canadian,
I'd say.
And he,
he blames it all on cable TV,
putting stories of crime in our face.
All right?
So I think there's a lot of truth to
that.
Now,
imagine social media channeling not just
stories of crime,
but whichever side you're on
politically,
you now get filtered through of all of
the stupid things that any person says
in our country of 330 million people
everyday.
Someone on the left says something
incredibly stupid and offensive.
And everyday some of the rights says
something you know,
and as a video.
And so if you're being.
So if you're rewarded for forwarding
outrage,
things that outrage you aside,
you're rewarded for forwarding them at
home.
We're all forwarding it.
We're all drowning in outrage stories.
And one of the things that that sells or
that sells in terms of getting retweets
is stories of aggression or violence or
racism or whatever it is.
People trampling on your side,
sacred values.
So if you're exposed constantly,
the stories of you know,
if you're,
if you're on the left,
you're exposed to stories of right not,
not season.
You think that half the country is,
this is going to have a big effect on
your perceptions,
even if even if the reality is social
progress,
even if the reality is increasing
safety.
So we do think that the reason why it's
so many things are going haywire,
not just in America but in many
countries is the Internet and social
media all hitting us.
At the same time,
globalization is the other factor,
a little more distant,
but I think their intersection
intersecting interacting in all kinds of
interesting ways that we don't yet
understand.
We talked about polarization on the
right than on the left.
And one of the things that struck me and
maybe I'm wrong about this,
is that I'd be particularly concerned
about the rise of the radical left.
And that's probably because I've been
immersed in the University of you and as
you already pointed out,
the left is overrepresented at least
among the social scientists and the
humanities and I suspect as well the
administration in the universities and
then I see as well people being
concerned about the rise of the radical
right.
But I certainly don't see the radical
right as posing a threat in the
universities and I can't see what sort
of threat the radical right is posing
because I can't get numbers.
So like when,
there are lots of stories about outright
types and about neo Nazis and white
supremacists,
but they seem,
I mean there was a white supremacist
rally in Washington about a month and a
half ago and I think they got 16 people
on a bus on the white supremacists side
and several thousand counter protesters.
And so I'm wondering to what degree the
radical right is,
uh,
like I don't know where they are
exactly.
So do you have thoughts about that?
Yeah,
definitely.
In my work,
I talk about this being the most recent
trend and we talk about this in the book
and it's not necessarily the radical
right,
but we've seen some of the talk about it
kind of like we have this sort of echo
chamber on the universities and there is
a sort of an echo chamber on the right
as well and those two have been a sort
of colliding with each other with each
other.
So we've definitely seen an uptick in
fire of liberal professors getting in
trouble for what they say on the
Internet,
what they say on twitter or facebook or
you know,
going on Fox News for example.
And we talk about a couple of examples
of that in the book.
Now this is so recent that we're not
going to have real data on it,
but it definitely is a noticeable change
for those of us who work on the front
line.
So it's important to look at the timing
here because we hear this a lot too.
And you know,
whenever we talk about something,
people will find out,
well,
what about the.
All right,
and what about the Nazis?
Um,
and when,
when we started this,
when Greg first notice what was going on
in 2013,
2014 and in our article came out in
2015,
the right had nothing to do with it now
that nobody had heard of the alt right
practically they weren't trolling on
campus.
So whenever the origins of the problem
on campus,
it is not a reaction to the right now in
2016,
um,
the right got a lot more attention and
it got much more sophisticated trolling.
And uh,
as I read a little bit about trolling or
the New York Times began to cover it,
it became really clear all you need is a
few people with a kind of a perverse
sense of humor and a few anonymous
Internet accounts and they can provoke a
gigantic reaction from the group that
they want to provoke.
And so I think in 2016 we saw the right
and into 2017,
that's where we start actually seeing
the cases of right wing movements to get
professors fired there.
There's some really nasty stuff coming
out of various sites on the right
flooding people's inboxes with rape
threats.
And death threats and racist rants.
So there's a lot of nasty stuff coming
from the right towards professors in
2017.
And since then it wasn't happening as
far as,
it wasn't anything new,
it wasn't really part of the story early
on.
So we've talked to six.
The polarization cycle of the problem we
believe is not originally from,
from the right,
although now they are a part of the
polarization cycle
right out of the darkness in that
manner.
I mean,
one of the things I've seen on youtube
and the other commentary sources that
I've be monitoring is a real increase in
antisemitic comments and it's hard to
tell.
Of course,
it's hard to quantify that,
but your appallingly common,
um,
on,
on youtube and on twitter as well.
Um,
and some of them are coded,
you know,
I think it's common place nowadays to
put your comment in three brackets which
indicates a,
an antisemitic origin or emphasis.
And so that's very pernicious.
But again,
we have no idea how many people are
actually engaging in this.
And it's a very difficult thing to,
to come to terms with.
Because like when I look at the United
States,
I think,
and more power to you that your
political dialogue is actually quite
balanced.
There's a fair bit of power on the left
and there's a fair bit of power on the
right.
Um,
the radical left seems to be
overrepresented in universities and
that's something that's unique.
I can't get a handle on the white
supremacists and Nazi types.
I mean,
I think Nazis are vanishingly rare.
I really believe that the white
supremacists types as well,
but,
but that doesn't necessarily mean that
it's not growing.
It isn't being cultivated in some sense.
Then the question is how much should we
react to it?
So I'm Jewish.
My mother told me when I was growing up
that America is the promised land for
the Jews.
It's not Israel.
Israel is the promised land.
Um,
I was raised to believe that America is
the promised land for the Jews.
Sure.
There was some antisemitism.
My parents,
we moved to Scarsdale,
New York,
and they could not join certain country
clubs.
Big Deal.
There were Jewish clubs,
there were clubs.
That's the way things were.
It was,
it wasn't perfect,
but compared to what?
Compared to the rest of the world,
God,
my grandparents got off the boat in New
York and didn't go onto Buenos Aires or
any,
any place else that was settled
originally by the Spanish.
Um,
so America is not an antisemitic
country.
Now.
What do we make of the fact that now
we're seeing all this antisemitic stuff.
What I make of it is that there are a
few assholes who are organizing and
doing this and am I triggered by it
because I grew up where occasionally you
come across a swastika,
like scratched into the bathroom stall.
You'd find the f word,
you'd find them Saturdays,
you'd find a drawing of a penis and
you'd see a swastika.
And my reaction was,
you know,
Yuck or bad.
And then I would go on with my day.
It wasn't a trigger.
But if we teach kids now,
if you find something on the Internet,
been triggered and of course you will
always find something on the Internet.
I will say though,
and this is just anecdotal,
but my.
I speak a lot of times in California and
some of the sort of anti Israel bleeding
into antisemitism is something that
I've,
I've seen really dramatic performance.
It's almost as if it's become stylish to
be so anti.
You're almost antisemitic.
At least certain circles.
And I spoke at the British Labor Party
for example.
For example,
I spoke at the 50th anniversary of the
start of the free speech movement way
back in 2014.
Uh,
I spoke at Berkeley and I'll be damned
if my speech was not in a room with a
lot of antisemites and there was even a
guy who was trying to address this
saying like,
oh,
and people want to call it antisemitic
and so wrong,
and then you finish that sentence.
But it's undeniable that the poison hand
of Zionism destroys everything it
touches.
And I was like,
okay,
that's,
that's A.
I think they,
I can understand wanting to call you
that.
So I,
I definitely,
I don't think it's in people's heads
that this is real and I've noticed it
most pronounced for some reason in
California.
Okay.
So here's the idea of.
So no,
one of the things that happened in
Germany in the 19 twenties was a
polarization process,
right?
I'm obviously much more severe than the
one that we're going through,
but I wonder if when the political
spectrum polarizes that I'm
ethnocentrism of a certain sort of rises
and drive something like antisemitism.
So maybe maybe when the left and the
right are relatively close together,
people aren't so obsessed with their
group identities or the extreme types
aren't.
But then with the polarization process
starts,
everybody locks harder into the group
identities and then anyone who's.
I don't know if it's anyone who's an
outsider is viewed with access to
sufficient.
But see the situation with the Jewish
people is complicated too because
they're often successful.
So I don't know if it's some perverse
interaction between ethnocentrism and
resentment for the,
for the successful,
that's.
It drives antisemitism during
polarization processes.
I'm trying to get,
get a finger organized,
you know,
trying to put my finger on it.
I think what you're,
what you're reaching for it here is this
phenomena that you suddenly these bursts
of intolerance.
What triggers that?
And here I turned to Karen Stenner of
political scientists,
didn't work at Princeton,
and now she lives in Australia.
She wrote this brilliant book,
the authoritarian dynamic published in
2005.
And what she says in there is that
authoritarianism is not a stable
personality trait.
It's a dynamic in which some people got
20 or 30 percent of the population,
um,
when they perceive that society is
coming apart.
That is,
you know,
I study morality,
we need a sense of shared moral order or
at times when we feel that the moral
order is secure,
violations aren't punished,
everything's fine.
Um,
there are other times when we feel
things are coming apart,
it's chaos,
it's Babel,
when that's happening,
people who have this predisposition to
authoritarianism,
it's like there's a button on their head
that gets pushed and they then become
intolerant against all outsiders.
And so she does experiments where she
gives a story about,
you know,
maybe it's Mexican immigration,
but it turns that that then makes know
if you present it in a threatening way
as Donald Trump does,
that doesn't just turn people against
Mexicans.
It turns them against lgbt Americans.
So it's a general dynamic of stamp out,
descend,
stamp out the outsiders,
get back to the purity of our group.
So when we have times of increasing
prosperity,
when we have peace,
when there's a sense of progress,
the pie is growing,
there is some sense that we are.
We have something in common,
then things get much calmer,
but a number of events,
a financial crisis may have contributed
to sense that there is not a growing
pie.
But I think again,
social media has made it so that if you
are prone to this and then you sign up
to any group that is concerned about
immigration or anything else,
you will now be so you will,
it will be come flooding into you really
powerful videos designed to press that
button over and over and over again.
And before you know it,
America goes from having,
you know,
50 Nazis to having 500,
maybe even 5,000.
It's not 5 million.
I really don't think there are five know
whatever.
It's not like two or three percent of
the country are Nazis.
So we've got to somehow learn to get
used to the fact that we've got to
somehow get back to judging by sort of
the average or the overall rather than
the individual extremes because now we
will be faced with the individual
extremes forever and also while we're
recommending books.
Amy Chu was political tribes talks a lot
about this too and it's really,
really an interesting stimulating.
Well partly what I've been trying to do
in my lectures.
So I'm lecturing to people and doing
this to some degree on youtube as well
as to emphasize the existence of the
Coleman Center.
For me,
that's a return to classic liberal and
and to some degree classic conservative
values,
I mean some intermingling of those.
So some emphasis on traditional,
well a traditional phenomenon like a,
like monogamous marriage,
but the
idea of the sovereignty of the
individual as part of that common
landscape that unites us.
And that seems to be quite useful.
Although I would go ahead,
just keep going.
I think this is a very important point
that if you go down the identitarian
path,
there is no clear endpoint.
Nobody can point to where this will end
in a good way.
So what's,
what's so interesting and here's one of
the most encouraging signs is that just
in 2018,
we are seeing an explosion of books
written by people who are not straight
white males who are saying identity
politics practiced in this way is a dead
end.
We need to,
we need to really emphasize what we have
in common.
And so I'll just read you.
I just started collecting a file,
put this online someplace soon.
Here are some of the books.
Here's something really interesting
things coming out.
Just recently,
Amy Schumer's book political tribes,
as Greg mentioned,
a Francis Fukuyama has a new book
identity.
The demand for dignity and the politics
of resentment just came out last week.
Uh,
Anthony Appiah isn't writing brilliantly
about identity politics.
Uh,
Jonathan Rouch,
uh,
I guess he's conservative,
but he's,
uh,
he's been writing again very,
about amy Chu and about other reasons
why identity politics is a dead end.
John mcwhorter,
uh,
has been writing brilliantly about how,
anti racism has become a religion a how
we need to start focusing on,
uh,
on that.
In that way I'm in Britain.
There are a number of,
of people of Caribbean origin had been
writing about this.
I just had dinner last week with your
shot.
Manji has a book coming up.
Don't label me.
So this is wonderful that we're seeing
all of these people just to all of them
identify as being on the left.
None of them are straight white males
and they're all saying we need to
rethink this.
And so we're,
we're thrilled because in our book and
chapter three,
we distinguished between common
humanity,
identity politics,
which is what Martin Luther King did
have any of the civil rights leaders,
which yes,
you need to demand rights for groups
that don't have them,
but you do it by appealing to our common
humanity versus common enemy identity
politics,
which is what intersectionality tends to
devolve into it.
So it doesn't have to be,
but it often is bastardized into let's
all unite against them.
Yeah.
No.
In Canada,
we've been pursuing a multicultural
policy and our prime minister is famous
for saying that Canada has no identity,
which I think is an absolute catastrophe
of an idea.
I mean,
if you think about the multicultural
landscape of the planet,
it's certainly produces records along
with diversity.
So the question is how do you bring
people from different communities into a
universal community and maintain piece.
And it seems to me that you do that
essentially by concentrating on the
sovereignty of the individual as the
fundamental marker for human identity
rather than rather than the group.
And I was thinking about
intersectionality,
which I think by the way is a painfully
obvious idea.
You know,
the idea that you could be classified
among many group dimensions and,
and if their social status consequences
to all of those and that they interact.
Um,
but I think intersectionality is
actually the discovery of the fatal flaw
of identity politics because if you drag
people down,
if you allow their group identities to
multiply and interact and you get to the
point where each individual's unique
nexus of group identities.
And I actually think that that's what
western culture discovered over the last
several thousand years,
that the logical end point is the
individual.
And if you take everyone's advantages
and disadvantages into account
optimally,
then what you do is you treat them as
individuals like there isn't any one
else liked them in some sense,
except in terms of their common say
divine value or something approximating
that.
If you followed it to its logical
conclusion,
then the worst aspects of identity
arianism would vanish.
Because as you say,
everybody ultimately unfortunately of
the 20 or 30 dimensions on which one
could categorize people.
It's really only three to matter.
It's straight white males.
That's really where it's at.
We're digging into,
you know,
because that that's actually
illustrative.
I would say to some degree of the actual
motivations.
There is all these identities and
hypothetically there's nothing to
distinguish them in terms of primacy,
even in terms of their effect,
say on socio economic outcome.
So then it seems to me to be a victim
victimizer narrative that's driving the
idea that it's straight white males,
that,
that in some sense have the,
have the phenomenal upper hand,
which is another thing I don't really
buy.
I mean,
most of the dangerous jobs are done by
men.
And so
who has power and wealth,
you know,
straight white man can plead guilty to
that,
that the world is not perfectly equal
across all categories.
But I think what we're seeing now in
very sharp relief since the Sarah John
Controversy in New York Times recently
is this red wine.
I think it was Wednesday instead of a
year or two ago.
Um,
there,
there are some people who see inequality
and want to end it.
There are other people who see
inequality and want to reverse it.
At the time I thought,
well that's interesting.
I wonder if that's true.
But I think the Sarah John Controversy
where the New York Times hired a young
Korean American,
a person to join the opposite of the
editorial page and it was discovered
that she had all these nasty anti white
entryway tweets.
And the fact that there was a discussion
and debate,
many people would say,
oh,
by definition there's no such thing as
anti white racism.
It's okay to say terrible things about
white people.
It's okay.
Here's the key thing.
It's okay to look at someone and based
on the way they look,
dislike them and treat them badly.
And if you think that's okay,
then this is the problem.
This is common enemy identity politics.
I think that's horrible.
We shouldn't be judging people based on
their race then that's,
you're probably supportive comments,
humanity,
identity politics as well.
I actually would like to push back
against the idea that it's just straight
white men anymore.
I felt like I always feel like
unfortunately,
sort of like the Stanford Palo Alto
Slash San Francisco Bay area is
unfortunately way ahead on these trends.
And I think one of the reasons why you
are seeing pushback from minority
members.
Well it's partially because for a long
time,
at least among the friends,
I don't really believe in this and
almost like a religious kind of way.
Um,
they're,
they're extremely guilty about simply
being cisgendered as a non transgender
that you,
you'll,
you'll see sort of this call out culture
applied to a straight black men for
example.
So I do think that we,
we've been falling deeper and deeper
down the rabbit hole where people are
realizing,
wow,
so this is just a permanent situation of
guilt and shame about an identity that I
have no control over.
That can't possibly be right.
Well,
the other thing we can point out too is
that even if you do make allowances for
the fact that let's say on average
straight white men are doing or have
done relatively well economically,
it's also very much worth pointing out
that it's a tiny minority of straight
white men who have been doing
spectacularly well.
You know,
so you have a distribution problem
within each with each,
within each ethnic identity group.
And so to say that because on average
the socioeconomic status of a given
group is higher than the status of
another group.
All of the people who are members of
that group are disproportionately
benefiting is actually a rather.
I'm in,
I would say a rather motivated and
resentful analysis because it is always
a tiny proportion of people in a group
that are doing spectacularly well and
then then you have to do something else
which is you have to look at that
proportion that are doing spectacularly
well and you have to decide about how
many of them are doing well because they
actually deserve it and how many of them
are doing well because they're
inappropriate rent seekers and I would
say because our culture is pretty damn
functional and because we do generate a
lot of wealth along with the inequality
that there's a fair number of people who
are doing just proportionately well who
are doing that by benefiting everyone
else and we're not very careful about
making those sorts of distinctions and
they're actually crucial.
Right?
So that's what we did.
So in chapter 11 we go into social
justice and many people have claimed
social justice is a meaningless term,
gets thrown around in certain ways.
People can't define it.
I'm digging into it.
We decided that it actually is
meaningful,
but we have to.
We have to break it down into its
component parts and so we go into what
is the psychology of justice and if you
focus on distributive justice,
aren't people getting what they deserve
based on their inputs?
Everybody recognizes when people are
being cheated that they're,
you know,
like in America now,
a lot of low wage workers,
the companies have found ways to skimp
on benefits and pay,
so that is a violation of of
distributive fairness.
People recognize that that is wrong if
that is disproportionately affecting one
race or if people are being cheated
because they are members of any identity
group.
That is a violation,
I would say,
of social justice or injustice applied
to identity groups that we think is a
very important concept.
Simply procedural justice.
If the criminal justice system ends up
for whatever reason,
getting better representation to some
groups than others or treating people
differently at any point,
that is a violation of justice,
which can possibly quality violation of
social justice.
What we pushed back against is the shift
in recent years to this obsessive
emphasis on outcomes.
Social justice argument seems to be on
campus as you just say,
look,
men are overrepresented among coders.
Well,
they're not overrepresented among all
other functions at Google and apple.
If you look at everyone else in the
company,
you know it's 50 slash 50.
We're very close.
It's only in certain job classifications
where there's a disparity and so people
take that as ipso facto proof of
systemic sexism,
but we really push back hard on saying
that's lazy.
That's unfair,
that's inaccurate.
That's an invitation.
Those disparities or an invitation to
look closer and if you see that the
pipeline is 50 slash 50,
but the outcome is,
well then you've got a strong case.
But if the pipeline from Grad programs
and computer science is exactly the same
as the representation among coders at
Google and apple,
well you know,
you have to do something to show that
people are being treated differently.
So we think there's a lot of bad
thinking gun in the service of
prosecuting one's political agenda
within the culture war and that a lot of
people don't know how to stand up to it.
And one thing that I find interesting
but district become a blast from this
argument is a personal preference,
particularly when people talk about
gender.
So I mean if you've ever actually read,
for example,
the speech that got Larry Summers and so
much trouble,
incredibly conclusion is it's probably
mostly that these are not,
a lot of these jobs are not our job.
So the,
a lot of the theoretical physics things,
they don't have a lot of appeal to
women.
He,
he basically,
he comes down for some reason saying
that there might actually be a reason
why no veterinary sciences,
overwhelmingly women,
some of some of these mathematical
fields are overwhelming.
Mimic,
might have something to do with it.
Some small differences in what people
actually liked doing somehow.
So the biggest London Times just did an
article this week on two papers that
came out,
um,
was quite an interesting article because
one of the papers came out showing once
again that the personality differences
between men and women are largest in the
most egalitarian societies.
And they actually get quite large by
psychological standards in countries
like Holland or the Netherlands.
And also in the Scandinavian countries,
which are the most egalitarian
countries,
but the biggest difference between men
and women and also one that grows in
more egalitarian countries is an
interest and that that
difference is more than the standard
deviation.
It's like one and a half standard
deviations.
And so it's more than enough to account
for the disparity between male engineers
and our female engineers and male
nurses.
And the fact that it grows as societies
become more egalitarian is actually a
death blow to social constructionist
theory.
That's right.
So,
so let's go into this because this is a
really helpful area where I think we
have a good idea what's going on and we
can see why it's so hard to find.
Find the truth here.
Um,
so when I taught at Uva,
I had a lecture on sex and gender and I
went into sex differences and have clear
finding for many decades is that if you
look at differences in ability between
men and women,
they're very few and far between.
Men are better at spacial rotation.
Women on some images are a little bit or
at social skills and language.
So there are some differences,
but they're few and far between.
If you look at the differences in what
kids like and what they choose to do
when there's no adult watching,
their huge little boys and girls play
radically differently by my wife and I,
we,
um,
we once gave up my triplet nephews and
they were four years old,
four years old again from a bag of
plastic dinosaurs and the two boys
grabbed a dinosaur and they start
battling the bashing them together and
the girl takes two dinosaurs and she
says,
don't ever leave me money.
I won't be so dope.
But the point is girls and boys play
really differently.
And if you,
if they're supervised by adults,
the differences get smaller was if you
let kids play on their own,
the differences get bigger.
Differences in interest are huge and
crucial.
Finding.
Jordan,
I'd like to ask you what,
why,
why is this?
Why do you think this is treated so
much?
Like heretical.
Bless was thought that must be
immediately shot down,
that you zeroed in on the property issue
before.
When you talked about the equity Dr.
now,
one of the things I've been trying to
figure out is how we know when the left
goes too far.
Now we know when the right goes too far,
when they start making ethno nationalist
claims of superiority.
It's something like that and claiming
that all the good things should happen
to one ethnic or racial group.
Okay.
Know where you're outside the domain of
reasonable political discourse at that
point.
Now obviously the same thing can happen
on the left,
but when it happens,
it's not so obvious.
There's no smoking pistol,
but I think emphasis on equity,
which is code word for equality of
outcome is actually the smoking pistol.
If you had to pick one.
No.
Okay.
I would disagree with you on that.
That can't be a smoking pistol.
Emphasizing equity can't get smoking.
Pistol,
I think we mean by smoking pistol is
when someone makes an argument in good
faith trying to understand some
phenomenon in the world and they suffer
social consequences.
That's the smoking pistol.
Why we might be talking about two
slightly different things.
I'm.
I'm maybe not.
I'm trying to figure out where the.
Where the tipping point is on the left
that makes things spiral out of control
and you guys talked about the equality
of outcome doctrine as as the wrong.
First of all,
it doesn't allow for multivariate
analysis.
Right?
Which is a big problem,
so it oversimplifies things radically if
there's a difference in outcome than
ipso facto.
There is a victim,
victimizer,
a narrative driving it or reality
driving it and I think that the,
the,
the fundamental problem on the radical
left is exactly that and that's the
reason that they don't like the
literature on gender differences because
you can point to gender differences in
outcome and you can use them as proof
for the oppressive nature of society,
but if you look into it and you find out
that that's actually not proof that some
of the differences,
even some of the differences in outcome
are being driven by things like
biological difference in interest than
it radically weakens that central
axiomatic claim of fundamental
oppression.
And so that's viewed as an existential
threat by people for whom that's the
cardinal presupposition is.
That's how it looks to me.
That is correct since since reading the
righteous mind,
I always like to analyze things in terms
of what sacred,
organized.
They circle around it,
that binds them together.
There are a lot of things that people
hold sacred,
you know,
on all sides,
but I am struck by the fact that in the
academy it's not just questioning sacred
values of any sort.
It's specifically questioning diversity
policies.
That seems to be the most dangerous
thing to do and that does fit with what
you said that it's like it's a big
project that we're all engaged in and
we'll working hard against the enemy and
we're fighting the fight and if one of
us steps out and said,
well actually maybe we'll wrong on this
point.
Bang,
we've got to shoot them.
We can't have got to shooter.
Yeah.
Now that probability would be
proportionate to the centrality of the
axiom.
I think the central axiom here,
that's it's causing all the trouble,
is the insistence that the best way to
insistence's one.
Is that the best way to characterize
Western society as an oppressive
patriarchy?
That's right.
Yes.
And,
and the second is that the best way to
characterize people is by their group
and those two things interact.
And so the gender data is particularly a
horrifying,
I would say to people who hold those
axioms because,
well,
for two reasons,
one is because the gender differences
actually exist and they do account for
differences in outcome,
but even worse,
and this is a catastrophe,
I think for the social constructionist,
is that as you put egalitarian social
policies into play,
that the very differences that you hate
get bigger.
And that's,
and this needs to be said a thousand
times because it really is,
it's,
it's a fatal blow to the social
constructionist egalitarianism and even
to the concepts they're using.
Because one thing we could also ask is
like,
well,
if turns out that men and women are as
different in egalitarianism societies as
boys and girls are in there,
unsupervised play,
I think is a reasonable analog,
then we're going to have differences in
outcome that are going to be magnified
by the very policies that the
egalitarian or putting in place.
And then we also might ask to his inner
truly,
uh,
in this society that we want to set up,
maybe wouldn't have wanted to be the
case that people's free choice would
determine their occupational outcomes
and then we have to put up with a
certain degree of inequality of outcome
and think in a complex way about it.
We were talking about about sacredness
and one of the stories we talked about
in the book,
I know you're very well familiar with
the Rebecca to bell story paper,
an academic paper talking about,
well,
if we accept transsexuality,
what implications does that have for
someone like Rachel woke,
kind of wants to decide what,
what a,
what a racist.
She claimed that she was black heels,
black inside.
And um,
and,
and both John and I are very,
we've really tried to sort of be
reasonable as possible,
aggressively reasonable.
Um,
but in that,
in this one we,
uh,
we,
we liken it to,
um,
a male Durkheim's definition of witch
hunts because it really,
unfortunately really set because you not
only do you have this kind of like,
you know,
like normal,
interesting intellectual exercise of an
academic article and making an
interesting point.
It,
she's treated absolutely like a blast
summer and so badly that people are
signing letters condemning her while at
the same time emailing saying,
oh,
this is really terrible what happened to
you.
Um,
and it's just absolutely bizarre and
scary as the smoking gun proves that
there's a problem is when there are
social consequences to make good faith
are out in the public square.
If you're in the comments section on
Youtube,
of course we're trying to do with
universities,
is this really unique and important
thing which is create an environment in
which people are expected to challenge
each other.
We're not supposed to be there to be
agreeable and it all makes sense.
It's all okay because it's the surface
service of finding truth.
And as soon as people who are taking
part in that process are shamed,
punished,
excluded,
there calls to expel them or punish
them,
as soon as that happens,
now we have more of a sort of east
German mindset where people are not
thinking about what's true,
they're thinking about,
you know,
what will,
what will avoid getting in trouble,
what am I allowed to say by the fact of
what will get me incredible praise for
being,
throwing myself as a true believer.
Tremendous amount of authority is
motivated by the desire to avoid being
shunned and treated as the violator up
at taboo because that's exactly what's
happening is that there are,
there are new taboos.
So then part of the question might be to
why is there such an insistence that the
culture we live in is a patriarchal
tyranny,
which is also a collapse of complexity,
right?
I mean,
obviously our culture has its flaws.
It,
it tends towards,
um,
rigidity and tyranny,
like all cultures do.
But comparatively speaking,
as we've talked about before,
by,
by world standards today or by world
standards,
historically,
it's a pretty damn free and,
and productive culture.
But we have this tremendous emphasis on
the idea that it's fundamentally a
patriarchal tyranny,
and that if you a question that then
you're treated as a taboo violator.
So then the question is,
well,
what the hell is driving this insistence
that it's a patriarchal purity with,
with Kate Millett?
No,
you see who originated,
at least in part patriarchy theory.
You see that she had a very,
she had an alcoholic and abusive father.
And so I think that's quite interesting
because I think there are psychological
dynamics here at work.
I,
I wonder to what degree the people who
are pushing this theory,
um,
have had very disturbed interpersonal
relationships,
gender relationships,
and that,
that's,
that's what would you say driving the
collapse of their political viewpoint in
to a single dimension like a single
oversimplified dimension.
You see that sort of oversimplified
thinking when you look at,
at,
at psychopathological complexes,
you know,
like with,
with,
uh,
with women,
with eating disorders in particular,
what men too.
But that's rarer.
Everything collapses to a single,
uh,
a single dimension of evaluation.
Something like thin equals beautiful or
thin equals good.
And then that drives everything.
And so,
and then I also think maybe it is this
also a challenge too to cultural
tradition,
an actual intellectual challenge.
Say,
well we think that your,
your,
your way of,
of,
of operating within the culture is too,
too radical.
That we're going to throw everything we
can at you and an attempt to make you
prove that that's not true.
But I,
I can't get any farther underneath it.
The math.
So you're a clinical psychologist.
So I think your first impulse is let's
look to the person's formative
experiences.
Why do they think this way?
I'm a social psychologist.
So I think in terms of if there's some
new or some interesting social movement,
what are the social forces and pressures
on them that led them to think this way?
I also read a lot and think a lot about
evolution.
I like,
and this is what first drew me to you.
You went through when I met in 1994.
We both loved Carl young and I love this
idea of archetypes interpreted from an
evolutionary point of view as to like,
why do we dream about dragons?
Why do so many cultures have dragons?
Well,
actually,
you know,
our ancestors,
60 million years ago,
actually,
we're in a world of dinosaurs.
That's a pretty cool idea.
I don't know if that's right.
Anyway,
I'm human beings have a tendency to
think in a manichaean style.
It's effortless.
It's default for us to divide the world
into good and evil.
And that's why the third grade on truth
in our book is the untruth of US versus
them.
Life is a battle between good people and
evil people.
It's very hard to teach this to people.
Um,
so,
uh,
so we think that is innate as a
possibility.
And then the question is why are some
movements now teaching this and why is
it making more progress in some areas
the university now than it was 10 or 20
years ago?
Um,
so I think that,
to answer your question,
if you were engaged in a,
in a radical program,
radical means you want to tear things
down,
you want radical change,
you need to demonize the country to the
structure.
You want to tear down,
you need to say that America is the
worst.
America is a paragon of racism and
sexism.
And of course we have our problems.
You know,
most of us think that things have been
getting steadily better since the 19th
century.
Um,
but you're committed to saying that
America is the worst.
So there was an interesting study
published a few months ago,
if you've probably heard about this,
it rent America as like the,
like the twelfth worst country on earth
for women.
It was behind,
you know,
Eritrea and Sudan and you know,
North Korea know it was the one of the
worst places on earth to be a woman.
And you know,
just on the smell test and really like,
um,
you know,
I don't want to go into why that's so
wrong.
But at the methodology it was,
it was judged by her.
I can't remember what it was.
But despite,
obviously it was in the judgment of like
human rights activists or something like
that,
rights activists are generally many of
them,
and just American human rights activist.
I was something like that.
They are not weighing up statistics on
how women fare around the world.
They're being asked what are the worst
countries for women?
And if you were engaged in the project
of critique in America,
you're motivated to say that America is
the worst.
And that's explained that ranking
that justifies your continued activism
and if that's what you've staked your
career on them,
that's also necessary.
I also think that's one of the things
that's driving all of the things that
we're talking about is that we've
produced a committed activists class
that has been heavily subsidized for 30
years and they are always in need of
reasons to justify their continued
existence.
I mean,
as,
as we all are,
of course,
but,
but this is a situation where that's
become dangerous,
committed activists class.
Um,
I think this is important also to focus
on for a moment because in discussions
of this,
we're all supposed to praise the
students political activity.
We're all supposed to praise activism,
um,
and you know,
Pepsi tried that disastrous commercial
of just like,
you know,
random beautiful people being activist
because if you have a bullhorn,
bullhorn,
that's political activity goes.
So I think there is an idea among young
people,
and this is I think more true on the
left,
that to be political is to be
protesting.
Just telling me like why is it that the
right when they're upset about
something,
they go and they get people to the
school board and they changed the rules.
Like the right I think is more pragmatic
in its politics.
The left is more expressive and I think
this is a point that Mark Lilla has been
made so ultimately ends up backfiring.
But I think that the,
the,
the respect that we accord to activism,
pure and simple.
I think that should be rethought and I
might be about to do that.
One President of a major university in
this,
in this region recently said something
to the effect that universities are
becoming ungovernable now.
There's a lot of reasons for that.
They face a lot of pressures,
but the student activism,
the fact that it's,
it's.
It can be anything.
It's not addressed at injustice.
It's addressed at something in the
dining hall,
something that a student,
but it's because there are protests
about almost anything I think many
administrators are realizing what have
we done,
what kind of Frankenstein monster have
we created by incentivizing and praising
this kind of of,
of,
of activism.
Our whole being talking to politicians
in Canada about the possibility of
making a distinction between education
and activism and political activism.
So you know in Canada if you're a
charitable organization,
you can't engage in political activism
now.
It's very difficult to distinguish
between what might constitute education
and what might constitute activism,
but the idea that there's something
intrinsically moral and noble about,
about,
about complaining about the evil people
in the world is definitely something you
don't want literature.
The humanities used to be the antidote
to that to some degree because one of
the things that characterize is great
literature as opposed to secondary
literature is that if the literature is
great,
the battle between good and evil occurs
in the hearts of each protagonist,
right?
It's a psychological issue and not a
sociological issue.
I'm turning here to our opening quotes.
Um,
and we already talked about one instance
of one of our three opening quotes,
the line dividing good and evil cuts
through the heart of every human being.
And that is what we should be teaching
students to complexify situation to the
extent that we teach them.
No,
it's simple.
If you know the category,
you know their moral valence and you
know there are bad.
And so you've sent that.
We are teaching students to think in
this way.
We are harming them.
You're setting them up for failure.
We are preparing them for citizenship in
a democracy and we are harming the
future of our country.
And I probably have,
I have a
little bit of insight,
a as a first amendment lawyer,
um,
as someone who's spent a lot of time
defending the rights protestors and I've
dealt with very many protestors who were
protesting utterly sensible things that
I'm like absolutely more power to you.
But also I've talked to other people who
I felt were tilting at windmills or,
or,
um,
one time representative group that was,
or Algebra represented group that
believed that the US should have no navy
I'm talking about.
So it's not that you think we should
spend less on military,
but we should literally have no navy.
And that was the argument and I would
ask some of my activist friends in San
Francisco,
some of them were doing,
I think particularly with criminal
justice and that kind of stuff,
but another case.
So they'd see sort of activists sort of
groups that were,
you know,
for example,
I opposed the second Iraq war.
Um,
but I had friends who also oppose it
would immediately go into a and nine
slash 11 was a conspiracy to,
to allow for the.
I'm like,
why are you moving it to that next
argument where you're going to lose more
people and the perception was that we
have to keep the temperature at boiling
point,
we have to keep it a to 12 or else
people will lose interest and I actually
to in pinker is actually more correct on
this is that we're actually creating
virtually through some some of the
postmodern is thoughts that we're
creating,
a situation in which actually progress
is more or less hopeless and all you can
really do a shout about it,
which actually makes people more cynical
and does less to achieve your goals.
Whereas as pinker likes to point out,
if we actually look at,
well,
what did we do that actually works and
try to keep doing that,
that's probably a better bet for actual
progress knowing.
Welcome,
perverse thing there too is that I
believe this to be true.
John,
you mentioned that there's been a
variety of books coming out.
Maybe I could get that list and post
them in the description of this youtube
video that might be useful,
but there's also a whole string of books
that's been published lately,
including Steven Pinker's book,
enlightenment,
now showing that the rate of economic
progress around the world,
especially with regard to lifting the
abjectly poor out of poverty is
increasing at an unparalleled rate and
that might be a secondary benefit to the
collapse of communism since 1989.
A lot of things are driving it,
but certainly some of it is the spread
of ideas of individual sovereignty and
the use of free market policies by
developing countries.
Just as we see the,
the landscape for poor around the world
to be radically improved during this
process and the west of criticizing our
fundamental principles to the point
where we're.
We're driving a dangerous level of
polarization.
And so that's our very perverse and
strange situation and difficult to
contend with.
So.
All right,
let's,
let's switch a bit here.
One of left.
Okay.
So while we see the problem,
the problem is that we're still
sketching it out and trying to
articulate it,
but it's something like the rise of a,
a victim,
victimizer culture that might be driven
by young people's increasing sense of
vulnerability as a consequence of the
unexamined effects of social media,
the big polarization driven by tendency
for a dying media to come to concentrate
on extremism,
the domination of the intellectual
discourse in the universities by the
left and the radical left.
All these things are playing together
and they're causing a certain amount of
trouble,
like the rise of this excessive safety
culture that has negative psychological
consequences.
All right,
that's all dangerous.
What do we do about it,
Jonathan?
You have the Heterodox Academy.
So.
So that's,
that's,
that's something you've put into
practice that was designed to increase
viewpoint diversity.
Do you think that's.
What's your sense of that?
What's the consequence of that?
Yeah,
so the problem is,
as you said,
as we say in the book,
there's six different separate
contributing factors all coming
together.
The solution is not easy.
Let's break it down into what do we need
to do to get our universities
functioning better,
what do we need to do to raise kids who
are more resilient and more able to deal
with difference?
Let's focus on those two.
So let's.
So let's start with universities.
So,
uh,
I cofounded Heterodox Academy,
if you go to Heterodoxacademy.org
with Nick Rosenkranz,
last caller and Chris Martin,
a Grad student in sociology and then a
bunch of other social psychologists,
um,
because we were concerned that this is
just a faculty initiative that
discussions among professors of
psychology and research and psychology
was showing signs that certain
hypotheses wouldn't be investigated.
Other interpretations were favored.
We were seeing signs and almost all of
us were on the left or center.
There are,
there's only two conservative social
psychologist that I know of.
We were concerned about research
quality.
That's all it was.
And so we ended up putting up this site,
went live on or about September 10th,
2015.
Totally unrelated to that.
Greg and I had been writing the Atlantic
article totally separate track and then
all hell broke loose at Halloween in
2015 and it became clear this isn't just
a faculty issue.
The problem on campus is a culture issue
in which in which student,
this new form of student activism,
this new form of student,
that belief in fragility is affecting
how we do our research,
how we educate,
so all problems are interrelated a bit
to focus on the faculty issue.
What we're doing in Heterodox Academy.
Provisionally,
when I was running it,
I thought the issue was,
well,
we have no political diversity.
We need to get more.
We need to encourage more conservatives
and Libertarians to get phd's and then
we need to help them get jobs.
That's what I thought originally,
but over time the problem has morphed a
and it's become clear.
We do actually have some diversity in
every field.
Not everybody is on the left.
A lot of people are in the center or
libertarian or they say,
I can't be putting a box,
and what we have to do is encourage
those people to feel that they can speak
up,
they can question dominant ideas,
they can be a little subversive.
Um,
they have to make it so they're not
afraid of social consequences for
speaking of.
So that's the way that I was thinking
about it now.
Uh,
in Janet,
last January,
I turned over a heterodox academy.
I hired an amazing woman,
Deborah.
She's a professor at Harvey Mudd
College.
She is leaving that job to run heterodox
academy full time deb studies
relationships.
She's a great teacher.
She is moving the organization to focus
more on helping,
helping campuses recreate that climate
that we all know and love.
I mean,
you know,
we,
I love being a professor.
I love universities.
I'm deb is focusing on how do we prepare
students.
And so we've talked a lot about this in
the book.
What do you do at orientation?
What are the norms you made clear about
speech and free speech.
Of course we need to do training in
diversity and inclusion and sexual
violence,
all that stuff,
but how many schools trained for free
speech?
Pretty much none of them.
Then the fact that we don't mention any
of these deep philosophy,
major concepts that will be deep
philosophical underpinnings of academic
freedom,
freedom of speech,
but there's just so much we can complain
about students not knowing them when
nobody's actually thought.
So
it's been really interesting on this
lecture tour and find out how receptive
people are to exactly that kind of
message,
you know,
and I've been beating the drum,
let's say four or more conscious
understanding of the relationship
between meaning and personal
responsibility because one of the things
we also teach students is that,
um,
the proper focus for them is the
violation of their intrinsic rights as
if the upholding of those rights is
going to provide them with a sustaining
meaning in life.
But I don't believe that that's true.
I think that what's,
what's more true is that most people
find a sustaining meaning by adopting a
fairly heavy burden of personal
responsibility partly for themselves and
partly for their family.
And partly for the broader community and
that,
that that just seems to have dropped out
of the public discourse in its entirety
and then also what could be taught to
incoming students is this clinical
doctrine that we've been describing,
which is well,
how do you make yourself stronger while
you expose yourself voluntarily to
challenges that are outside of your
domain of current competence and that
often involves confronting things that
not only that you think are frightening,
but you might also think are disgusting
because that's what happens with
obsessive compulsive disorder treatment,
you know,
and discussed,
obviously runs a motivates some of this
political polarization.
That's right.
Somebody alerted me,
somebody as civil rights scholar told me
about how the marchers in the sixties,
how they trained and here they are going
in to a staging,
protests going in,
doing sit ins facing real violence,
and some of them were actually killed.
The way they prepared for it was others
would shout racist slurs at them.
They will be prepared for it.
They would expose themselves to the
worst and then when the worst happens,
at least it was less painful than had
they not encountered it.
So again,
over and over again,
we see.
Are you,
is your goal to toughen yourself up?
Is your goal to become stronger and more
able to deal with the world as it is or
is your goal to demand
that somebody make the world other than.
Yeah,
which is the which is the more reliable
path to success in life.
I'm in both John and I,
I'm president of fire and through
Heterodox we're both trying to also
figure out ways to get to people well
before they set foot on a college
campus.
No,
certainly I think it's kind of
unforgivable that most universities
don't teach about some of these
philosophies and concepts in
orientation,
but you should be learning about some of
these ideas when,
when you're,
when you're in high school.
So one thing that John did that I'm
totally jealous of is they did a graphic
novel version of a part of chapter two
of on liberty about freedom of speech as
a great way to tell a generation
students about.
And I also just love on liberty
predictably argument,
freedom of speech as a lawyer because
I'm like this guy because this guy
argued being able to defend the decision
to defend blasts one meal to go up
against blasphemy prohibitions at 18,
59,
but then managed to say,
and by the way,
you know,
who suffered under blasphemy laws,
Jesus and socrates guess enforced them.
Marcus Aurelius also one of your heroes
and it's like you just won the case.
You're a world class.
So let me suggest that viewers go to
Amazon and look up all minus one a or go
to heterodoxacademy.org/mill.
We can get a free version of pdf or you
can have a $3 kindle version of it as
well as the printed Arco.
Great.
Put that in the description as well.
So yeah,
so high school,
any high school that wants to teach
about free speech and sign this,
it's extremely readable by high school
students.
It's just chapter two,
cut by 50 percent.
And metaphors are illustrated.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well,
so the free speech issue too.
So one of the concepts that I've been
wrestling with is we have to produce
hierarchies in order to accomplish tasks
collectively and we have to accomplish
tasks because they're suffering to
address real problems to solve.
So we're going to produce hierarchies
and hopefully the hierarchies are
predicated on merit in relationship to
the solution of the problem.
And so the right winger types are more
inclined to support hierarchical
structures because of their
psychological predisposition and the
left wingers are more likely to be
concerned about the fact that the
hierarchy's inevitably dispossessed
because they'll produce on equal
distribution of resources.
Okay.
So then you can imagine that the
political landscape is a battleground,
are permanent battleground between those
who stand for the hierarchies and note
that they have their utility but are
perhaps blind to their proclivity to
become tyrannical.
And those who are more sensitive to the
claims of the dispossessed and worried
about the proclivity of tyranny,
of hierarchies to become,
um,
predicated on nothing but power.
At some points the hierarchy is going to
be weak and need to be strengthened.
And the other points,
there has to be more clamor on the side
of the dispossessed and the reason you
have free speech as far as I'm concerned
is because it's the mechanism that keeps
those two to opponent process,
opponent process processes balanced.
And so it's a core,
it's the core element of a free society
because it's actually the process by
which the society maintains and improves
itself across time.
So it's not just another value among
many values
is one of the founding fathers were
really good evolutionary psychologists.
Um,
and one thing that I love about working
in constitutional law is just how both
pessimistic and optimistic it was at the
same time were the tensions of Alexander
Hamilton and Madison were so concerned
about like,
how do you,
how do you balance out these natural
human,
it's human nature.
Whereas today,
you know,
we're supposed to claim the reason.
There isn't any such thing as human
nature on.
The other thing is I have a slightly
different philosophy on,
on freedom of speech.
It's actually much simpler than a lot of
sort of like the more sort of like
platonic,
platonic ideal of truth,
which is simply that it's always
valuable to know what people really
think as simple as that sounds.
It does mean that when people say,
well,
you certainly certainly you shouldn't be
listening to conspiracy theorists and
what they,
what they say about stuff.
And I'm like,
if it's a popular conspiracies,
shouldn't you have some clue about what
some of the population actually thinks
about things?
And I think that we,
we,
uh,
that understanding what people you
despise actually think and believe is
always a value because the project
itself is a project of human knowledge.
No one human beings as they actually are
not as we wish they were.
I can use that terminology.
It's like if I want to know what you're
going to do and I do,
especially if I happen to be near you
or,
or have you or have to interact with you
repeatedly.
If I know what you think and I can
understand how you're going to ask,
and if I don't know how you,
how you think,
partly because you're not allowed to
express it,
then you're an opaque mystery to me and
the probability that we're going to
engage in conflict goes up tremendously.
So I mean there are multiple reasons for
for the,
for protecting the sanctity.
Let's say a free speech.
Now,
one of the things that really distresses
me about the postmodern slash neo
Marxist philosophy is that there isn't
any room in that philosophy for the idea
of free speech.
Know this is something I've come to
understand more deeply over the last two
years.
When you're talking to someone from that
theoretical.
They can't engage in the discussion
about free speech because it doesn't fit
into their worldview because all there
is.
There isn't sovereign individuals
engaging in a discussion about the
nature of reality.
There's avatars of their power group
unconsciously making claims on behalf of
their privilege and that there's never
free speech there because you don't want
a free agent.
You're not even a real entity as an
individual.
And,
and,
and that's a far more pernicious assault
on free speech than mere objection to
it,
as you know,
a,
a right wing as something that's been
hijacked by the right wing to,
to validate their power,
their particular privilege,
because this is one of the main
arguments that we get back,
is a free speech is just a way for the
powerful to retain their power.
Greg's cause when the Nazis started
having rallies for free speech.
So that's really not what you want.
What's your response when people say
free speech is just to help some
powerful.
It drives me nuts because it's a
fundamental misunderstanding of history
and government and political philosophy.
And I've,
I've had this argument with Stanley fish
and it seemed like a total shock to him.
I'm sure it'd be thought of it before,
but you don't need a special protection
of an individual,
right?
I'm in a democracy.
Um,
uh,
for the majority,
you,
first of all,
rich people and powerful people under
any system of government where rich
people's under communism,
you know,
don't do so well.
Um,
once they take over,
but after they take over,
you know,
like the KGB people get rich and
powerful.
People are always going to be fine.
If you set up a democracy,
I'm,
the majority is always,
if there's a consistent majority,
the majority is always going to be fine.
You only need a special protection of
freedom of speech for minority points of
view.
No,
I know.
It's absolutely amazing that that's not.
And John Roche and it was really
interesting.
Refresh has a lot of interesting because
he says it's like,
listen,
if you've reached the point where
there's enough,
uh,
enough people who are worried about your
wellbeing,
that they're willing to pass a law and a
majority country to get you protected.
It probably means the real dark days are
behind you.
Um,
and one of the things that we've talked
about me and Roche is that if we passed
an anti,
sort of a hate speech law saying the
late 19 sixties,
it would have frozen in place kind of
attitudes about homosexuality,
which he was concerned about.
And I think we would have ended up with
a law that looked a lot more like what
you see in Russia that actually ends up
being used against a gay people that
then then rather these sort of
progressive law that we hope it would
be.
But time and time again,
the idea that you like,
by the way I'm going,
I keep on trying to put this out to from
a very practical way like so you want
laws that define that,
that allow the government to stop
hateful speech and you want trump
and some.
There's an old military doctrine which
is whatever weapon you design your
enemies will have in 15 years.
And if you start putting restrictions on
something like free speech as a,
as a benefit to your ideological
position and you don't imagine that you
might be out maneuvered in their use by
your enemies,
then you're not sufficiently awake.
So when I did a lecture a year and a
half ago,
which was a left wing case for free
speech,
and I just thought that was self evident
for the reasons that you put forward,
which is well the powerful,
and you can use leftwing terminology
here,
the powerful have an a priori monopoly
on speech obviously.
And so you want to put protections in
place so that the dispossessed who you
hypothetically champion get a chance to
put their viewpoint forward.
And it's really,
it's quite a mystery that,
that that's not merely axiomatically
obvious now.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
it's not Caesar calling for free speech.
It's the easy thing to do is say,
okay,
well then it must be bad.
Yeah.
Yes.
Well,
okay.
So tell me,
let's go back to the book.
So how you said earlier when we talked
before the interview that it had,
you know,
in the New York Times bestseller list
and it seems to be selling well,
what are you hoping,
what do you see happening as a
consequence of your essay in the
Atlantic and,
and as a consequence of the book and
what you hope will happen,
like say over the next year if we're
going to be optimistic about where we're
headed,
what's going to happen?
So I felt for the last two years that
we're kind of in an emperor's new
clothes situation where most people who
are paying attention,
most people are involved in universities
or an education realized that something
wrong,
but they don't understand what it is and
nobody wants to appear insensitive.
The people don't want to stand up and
critique if it seems that you're pushing
back against it,
against the historical marginalized
groups in particular.
So there's been.
So university administrators,
we spoke to a lot of college presidents.
They're overwhelmingly,
what I would call it,
liberal left,
not illiberal.
I don't know of any college presidents
who are illiberal,
but they're often afraid to stand up for
what you've observed you to Evergreen
State University.
So.
Yes,
that's right.
That's right.
Yeah,
that's right.
So there's been a lot of desire to
change,
a lot of desire to restore some sense of
ordering community on campus that we can
do our work and our teaching.
Um,
and,
but,
but I'm hopeful that our book will do,
is give everyone a common set of
concepts and,
and sort of a look into how this thing
plays out if you,
if you don't do anything to stop it
going down this rabbit hole.
Um,
my hope for the book is that the
parenting stuff is,
is new.
That is a lot of people have been what's
going on on campus,
but they don't realize this is now
happening in high schools.
And so my hope is that every,
every school principal from elementary
school through high school and every
college president will get a copy of the
book in the mail or given to them by a
donor,
Jordan,
Jordan's large audience.
I hope that you will buy a copy of the
book and give it to the principal of
your kids' elementary school and
certainly
maybe we can put that in the description
as well.
Makes a great gift to the people who are
educating your children.
Right?
I'll,
I'll write that down right now.
Reaching parents.
So that's always the first constituency
we talk about because,
you know,
we hear it from parents over and over
again as parents ourselves.
There's this kind of like there's a
sense that something's really going
wrong in k through 12 education.
Certainty there's something more going
on than just the process of parenting
where most people feel kind of.
That seems like a lot of parents feel
sort of helpless because they don't have
that pluralistic ignorance problem.
They don't know that everybody else
having the same problems and as soon as
you actually get the conversation
started,
if we can get to parents,
we,
uh,
we have a real fighting chance.
Okay.
Alright.
Well,
um,
what,
what do you think?
Are you optimistic or pessimistic about
where this is going at the moment?
No kidding.
That's exactly.
You hit a little bit of both.
I'm very pessimistic about the national
situation.
I think polarization is going to get
worse for awhile while,
and so I think we have to think about
how do we adapt our institutions to life
in an increasingly polarized country.
So if know politics is,
is dominating everything and it's
getting nastier and Nastier,
it would be great if when you go into a
restaurant,
you don't have to think about,
is this a Democrat restaurant?
When you go into buy a pair of sneakers,
you don't have to think about,
is this a democratic pair of sneakers,
a Republican pair of sneakers?
So we maybe go into the rope to
everything is polarized,
everything's political.
That'd be terrible if universities to
come to that,
if this is a Democrat university or
public,
that would be terrible.
Um,
so I think on the national level I'm
very pessimistic,
but I think that there is enough
recognition that we're all exhausted.
This is,
this is out of control,
but I think we will have a,
it'll be possible to get a constituency
to say our elementary schools or middle
schools or high schools.
And universities,
they have work to do,
um,
uh,
we need to reform what we're doing in
ways that are better for the kids.
We all love our kids,
we all want our kids to be resilient.
So I like Greg,
I'm very optimistic that,
that the trend towards overprotective
parenting,
which has just been continuing on and
on.
I'm very optimistic that,
that will reverse once people see those
graphs once people and you talk to
parents of teenagers,
even if their kid isn't depressed,
seven of their kids' friends,
depressed or anxious.
Okay.
So let me ask you about that a little
bit and maybe we'll end with this.
Um,
I've been trying to figure out why this
overprotectiveness epidemic has emerged.
And so I took the social,
psychological root of analysis instead
of the psychological.
Because I do know you should look at
situational factors before you look at
app in personality factors.
Let's say generally speaking,
well,
here's some demographic trends.
Um,
fewer kids.
So maybe parents don't make their kids
resilient.
Maybe siblings do,
you know,
because there's a lot of,
there's a lot of uh,
uh,
what would you call status competition
between siblings and if you're special
or unreasonable,
[inaudible] your siblings are going to
have a field day with you.
And so,
you know,
maybe we can't raise kids that are
resilient unless they have three
brothers and sisters or something like
that.
That makes a lot of sense.
But my recollection was elicits a cela
what was it,
the guy who wrote birth order,
what was that book?
My recollection is that the effects of
birth out are actually very small.
And so whether you're a first or last,
whether you're an only child or not.
So research one back very far,
those effects are pretty small.
So I would not put this big change on
the factor of declining families because
you don't have siblings rather declining
families means there just aren't that
many kids in the neighborhood.
Yeah.
Well that's the other issue.
Sure,
sure,
sure.
Because more significant.
So then next thing,
next thing might be older parents know
we don't know how optimally stupid you
should be when you're a,
when you're a parent,
and it might be that you might need to
be somewhat narcissistically entranced
with your own life to ignore your
children enough to allow them to develop
independent resilience,
you know,
and if you're,
if now let's say you don't have a child
until you're,
well let's say 40,
you only have one or two,
so they're pretty damn precious and
you'd been waiting a long time and now
you're more conservative because you're
older because you will be and you have
endless resources to devote to this
extraordinarily valuable individual.
So,
so if it,
if it's,
if it's the consequence of it switch and
demographics and,
and,
and older parents,
then it's going to be a harder thing to
rectify as a consequence of
transformation of attitude.
Nicholas is major,
major theory on this stuff.
And at the same time,
you know,
you have to say some things that really
have changed.
And definitely what first,
I'm a first generation American.
I'm the,
uh,
but the idea that there's this sort of
like a,
of the stratification in the US in terms
of income is getting so dramatic and the
way you can get to that life raft is
getting into a princeton or Stanford
or Harvard,
um,
that,
that's not entirely in people's heads,
but unfortunately the way we thought
that,
the best way to do that is to build
these sort of rocket ship hyper invested
in.
We have two kids and you treat them
both,
like keep seeking missiles and you
completely eliminate any autonomy over
their lives.
They get up at six and they're scheduled
until they go to bed.
Um,
it turns out that this is visibly
dysfunctional.
At the same time,
it's why we interviewed Julie Haines who
wrote a book called how to raise an
adult about how,
you know,
freshmen are showing up at Stanford.
I'm depressed partially because they
have been no sense of locus of control
of their life.
So I think there is a really stunning
success that we found in researching the
book.
It's no surprise that meant if you
compare it,
if you go back to the 19 fifties and
sixties,
look at how men spend their time and
today it's no surprise that men are
spending more time in childcare and more
time with their kids.
That's great.
We all think that's great.
What do you think has happened to women?
Women were very rarely working in the
fifties and sixties and so look,
the number of hours they spent two and
childcare involve their children back
then getting us going up or down since
the fifties or sixties.
Now they most women are working.
Answer one more time with their kids and
there are very few kids now.
So you have mom and dad both spending
more time with their one or two kids
supervising over investing.
They're not a lot of kids out in the
neighborhood and investing poorly.
And that's important is right there.
That's right.
Because we're investing in a what?
A net zero calls.
Concerted cultivation.
We have the two,
the two.
Here's another.
Here's another conundrum.
So one of the things that struck me is
that a lot of this gender play that you
see gender roleplay that you see in
among adolescents now,
older adolescents and young adults in
university.
So the gender bender and gender fluidity
a games and I'm calling them games for a
reason.
They remind me of pretend play within
insistence by the player that everyone
joins the game.
And I've been thinking,
well maybe we're seeing a delayed
reaction to the eradication of fantasy
play in early childhood as a consequence
of the introduction of technological
devices.
Because you know,
the developmental psychologists know
very well that children have to engage
in a lot of fantasy play.
And then if you introduce technology
that that interferes with that or
supersedes if then the fantasy play
doesn't do occurred.
You're playing with different roles when
you're engaged in fantasy play.
So I'm also wondering,
you know,
because I noticed even when I had kids,
which is no for a long time ago,
often when I took them to the houses of
other people with kids,
instead of letting the kids go off and
caused a bit of trouble and then settle
into a spontaneous fantasy play episode,
they'd put on a video,
but now that's like 20 times is bad
because all kids have access to endless
electronic devices and we don't know
what that's doing to the early childhood
play and so well.
So anyways,
those are some of the sociological
forces that I thought might be at work
that are driving this hype of
protectiveness and if it isn't obvious
to see how to reverse them because
they're not happening consciously in
some sense.
Right.
It's not like everybody decided that
they were going to hyper protect their
children.
Yeah.
But I think social norms are very
powerful and if everybody else acts like
letting your kid walk a dog is
dangerous,
you'll be less likely to let your kid
walk the dog.
It should be possible to reverse that.
What we're hoping will emerge from this
book and our discussions,
the book is the norm that if you're not
letting your kid out,
you're harming your kid.
Almost like a vitamin deficiency.
I'd like to know if doctor story,
if pediatricians and the pediatricians
just put out a big report on the
importance of play at kids need a lot
more play than they're getting vitamin P
and how much vitamin P did your kid get
today?
And parents and vitamin D is not.
It doesn't count if you were there with
them.
So,
um,
so if we start,
if pediatricians aren't asking them how
much vitamin peg kid get less and only
tell me about the unsupervised time.
So,
so we look at the idea because you know,
so your point about the shrinking
families is,
is right and that's irreversible.
We're never going to go back to large
families.
We have to adapt to that.
And if you really want your kid to be
successful,
he'll back off.
That's the idea.
We have to get across.
Look,
your kid's going to have to encounter
the full tragedy of life as they mature
and become adults.
You're trying to do what you're trying
to do.
I mean,
there are all sorts of things.
So when Nisha said what doesn't kill you
makes you stronger,
the principle is true,
but it's not literally true and the
research on adverse childhood
experiences and we talk a fair amount
about advocating for that,
but certainly for goodness sakes,
you know,
the ability to get in fights with other
kids and resolved among themselves.
We got rid of that and now we have a
generation that's looking upwards.
Say whatever doesn't kill you,
makes you stronger.
So he certainly knew that something.
Right?
So it's a matter of optimal exposure to
challenge and it's by challenging your
kid's not five,
protecting them that you make them
resilient and they need to be resilient
because life is actually difficult.
And so,
you know,
one of the things that's been gratifying
to me too is during my lectures I've
been telling people that the idea that
they're okay the way they are,
especially if young is an appalling
idea.
What they could be concentrating on is
who they could be.
One of the really positive elements to
the notion of optimal challenges,
but it's really,
um,
it's encouraging for people to know that
you're willing to let them take a risk
because you have enough faith in their
ability to learn and prevailed that,
that supersedes the risk.
All right.
Well thank you guys very much
appreciated the discussion.
We'll get this up as soon as I get it
edited,
which shouldn't be too long and if you
would be so kind as to send me all the
url links you'd like me to post in the
description,
then I would be more than happy to do
that.
And good luck with your continued sales
of your book and with all your other
endeavors as well.
And hopefully a good sense will prevail
and we can do something to reverse this
polarization and to,
and also maybe to reduce the safety
culture on in the education system.
That would really be something.
Thank you,
Jordan.
Good to see you both.